what's the last half hour or so been
like for you what was the landing like
the landing we were just saying that it
was smoother than some other land is
reduced rate that it was incredibly
maybe slow down more they would normally
do but very smooth the whole process the
pilot but also the whole crew have been
very calm and we had none of us had
we're all busy googling and looking at
Sky News now we didn't realize that be
such a fuss because it's been such a
common experience you didn't we've all
been watching you circling over brighton
a nice porn for the last half hour or so
when did you first realize that
something was wrong when were the
passengers first told that something was
up we were often out an hour in and they
said we had to go back to Gatwick
basically and they said it was a
hydraulic problem not specifically the
wheels and although I spoke to my
traveling companions that I thought that
might be the pen and I would hope you
wouldn't be the case and but actually
the experience as being it shows how
professional flight crew and pilots on
how could the aircraft are because it
was in this text but really very you
know the way they handle the brace
position all the instructions that all
500 lee 47 passengers were kept calm
because the crew would come a bit of a
cuban thought it's at one point and
we'll get up for a while but really it
as an experience for anybody on the
flight probably less traumatic than
watching it on the TV you mentioned the
ghost thank God you know mmm you
mentioned the brace position there you
were presumably all refreshed on the
safety procedures for these kind of
landings before that landing was made
for you yeah that we were given a safety
brief you probably two hours before we
actually landed and then reminded a
number of times and then obviously when
we went through it is been can't proceed
yer because they'd run through through
it a few times and I mean I think that
was what alerted when they first said
brace position and emergency landing you
could see a sort of looked ass I go
through the plane but as we went on and
what we were going round around zhirkov
and try some procedures to release the
wheels people got used to the idea
and because the crew were so calm it
made us calm and you know you normally
go on these flights and you're more
worried about whether your foods can be
hot or cold or you know whether you're
going to be upgraded but really this is
what matters and the crew were amazing
fantastic when you adopted the brace
position as you are coming in to land at
Gatwick what was going through your mind
that you know even though the crew were
calm even though the rest of the
passengers are very calm I'm a bit of a
nervous flying myself and it's my worst
nightmare I said you wouldn't have been
wanting to take that position how did
you feel yeah he did feel nervous I the
tracking of the people in a row with me
of course you don't want to exaggerate
we're all thinking we just want this
over and done with we think it's going
to be fine but you're never sure are you
so they know yeah we were you just want
to be open done with its and we were
talking about going on a roller coaster
in Vegas when we got there that is off
the menu if we ever get there now you
don't need a roller coaster ride we've
been on this flight there were some
reports that there were a couple of
attempts to land earlier are you able to
tell us anything about that or was this
the only my god laughing we circled over
for that for the tower to look at us
with an oculus they made reference to
that that the captain that David Koepp
to the plaintiff that they were looking
at the flame as the doctors to check on
landing here so I think that's why they
going over no they were no intention we
were circling we jefferson's a lot of
fuel as well sort of quite a way out for
me over Wales so there was a lot of
planning and obviously they're on the
phone to failing as well that's what we
were informed of any way what's
happening now you're still SAT there on
the plane in your seat you can see all
the satellites texting burning loved
ones chatting and you're generally
people were just relieved it's a kind of
everyone gave a big round of applause to
the flight see when we landed you can
imagine that the relief amongst
everybody here have a fewer emergency
gin and tonics been consumed since
you've land actually your colleague cave
my former colleague suggested that and
that we were certainly we can't wait to
get back into the terminals that we can
have a gin tonic or vodka tonic
I Kevin another phatak yes from the
person sitting next to you on the plane
there yeah yes yeah we're just
definitely a that's on the agenda we
don't know what we're going to do about
getting out of the states now but we
just relieved to be down and you know
nothing but cutest virgin atlantic in
their cru fantastic teams and actually
extraordinarily calm experience to be on
this plane with them and if you can't
say better than that but thank you thank
God they knew what they were doing any
idea how long you're going to be on on
the plane we can see them the emergency
services there that the fire crews in
the ambulance is all standing by it
seems that they're not needed thankfully
there presumably trying to get the steps
up to the aircraft any idea how that's
going can you see anything other than I
just missed because I was chatting away
to you guys but I think they want to try
and level the plane off because of
leering to one side so they want to make
it stable and then they'll get us off
tonight I don't think it'd be that long
now I think we'd be off very soon and
are you still keen to travel on to
America a lot of people after an
experience like this however car might
say I think I'll just go home now but
but are you still quite cleaned it to
head back to the States I think yeah and
if you like it's like falling off a bike
you go get back on i think in this is
very you're more likely to get run over
crossing the streets so it's an unusual
it so i mean you never thing can happen
to you but I got it when it did happen
to us wheel we going to go down as one
of the greatest but emoji landings in
history I think it's very smooth but
we're lucky that fate played you this
hand it's that we've been inside